A fuel efficient Hummer? Impossible you say.
The gas mileage of a Toyota Prius with a hauling capability of a truck.
That's how David West of Raser Technologies describes the electric powered Hummer.
What we really need is something that has great gas mileage but also has a payload,...
...'cause we do stuff as Americans. We share rides when you go to the soccer game,...
...we don't wanna drive six Priuses to the soccer game.
We wanna drive one Hummer with all kids, all six kids in it.
Last week, US President Barack Obama unveiled some strict and sooner than expected fuel standards...
...for automobile manufacturers.
By the year 2016, he wants US cars and trucks to average about 15 kilometers per liter.
We have set in motion a national policy...
...aimed at both increasing gas mileage...
...and decreasing greenhouse gas pollution for all new trucks and cars sold in the United States of America.
President Obama's proposal would increase current auto fuel efficiency by about 30%.
Some argue that places a hardship on American auto makers...
...at a time when they're facing serious financial difficulty.
Gasoline's about $2.50 a gallon.
But David West of Raser Technologies says, their electric Hummer shows it can be done,...
...and it can be done in a car that consumers want to buy.
If you can make a hummer green, you've solved the big problem...
...because you can convert the rest of America's fleets to green technology.